hey youtubers is Charlie this week for
marvel Tuesday there is so much awesome
stuff going on this video is gonna be a
big update for all the things we know
about ant-man coming out next year and
tonight I'll be doing a breakdown of all
the New Avengers footage they're gonna
be posting this is a big Marvel special
going on it's gonna be a lot of fun if
you're finding me for the first time
I've just bookmarked Tuesdays going
forward as Marvel days be sure to
subscribe to get everything and if
there's any special Marvel movie video
you want to see just leave me a
suggestion in the comments below so here
we go let's talk some and man careful
for spoilers from the comic books but
the stuff we'll be talking about takes
place we know way back in the 1970s so
this happened a long time ago but number
5 elephant in the room there's one tiny
super major detail that they changed
about the characters in the comics Hank
Pym the first ant-man creates Ultron the
Avengers most infamous villain but
because of the way Marvel's movies have
unfolded and because they want all the
stories to integrate they had to change
that I covered Ultron's new origin in my
Avengers 2 video I did last week but the
ant-man movie if it does feature Ultron
will focus mostly on a different ant-man
the Scott Lang version of the character
quick side note though regardless of
whatever ends up happening in ant-man
I really hope there is an Ultron cameo
it would be totally blasphemous if the
character wasn't present at all number 4
the hero roster the movie will feature
Hank Pym played by Mike Douglas but the
main character is really Scott Lang the
second ant-man played by Paul Rudd if
you're not familiar with the comics
Scott Lang's run as the character was
less of a dark angsty story and more of
a fun series of adventures Hank Pym is
kind of like a version of Tony Stark
genius inventor who develops the ant-man
suit Scott Lang was actually a criminal
who stole the ant-man suit to save his
daughter over time Hank Pym then kind of
became this obi-wan Kenobi to him and
helped him to become a real hero
the movie is also going to star Michael
Pena and Patrick Wilson but we don't
know who those characters are gonna be
and we don't know if the wasp Janet Van
Dyne is character will be featured but I
would at least expect her to be
referenced since she's such a big part
of the ant-man story rashida Jones is
rumored to be in talks so she would be a
good candidate for that wasp character
there is a third version of the ant-man
in the comics Erik O'Grady the
irredeemable ant-man but he probably
won't be a part of the story it's really
just gonna focus on Paul Rudd and
superhero Jedi Master Michael Douglas
number three the movie is the official
beginning of Marvel's phase 3 coming
just three months after Avengers 2 based
on that they're probably going to be
addressing some of the things that
happened during Avengers 2 the Avengers
will probably defeat but not kill Ultron
and the infinity gems storyline will
develop more plus there's the continuing
presence of Coulson and shield because
that'll be happening during season two
of agents of shield
I'd say Nick Fury might be a part of
that too but all the teasers for Captain
America make it seem like he dies I
think it would be foolish to assume that
he will if they brought Coulson back
from the dead they can totally bring
back Fury - that being said phase 3 will
be the era of quote-unquote miracles
meaning that mutant abilities and more
fantastical stories will be happening
you know like magic it'll also feature a
changing Avengers roster Marvel has
already kind of responded to this by
saying that different villains like
Ultron and Thanos require a different
roster of heroes
number two the movie is directed by
Edgar Wright of Cornetto trilogy Fame if
you haven't seen any of his other movies
get on it they are amazing he's mostly
famous for Shaun of the Dead Hot Fuzz
and now World's End but he's also done a
ton of other awesome stuff and on top of
that he has a blog that he posts awesome
stuff too on a regular basis one of the
things I really love about Marvel
directors like Edgar Wright and James
Gunn of guardians Fame is that they're
highly engaged with the fandom it's like
whenever I do Q&A videos and include
your guys comments or do videos based on
your suggestions it just makes things so
much more fun whenever you know that
creative person behind something is
listening to you and really cares about
what you think and number one changing
Avengers roster well in the comics under
the tutelage of obi-wan Hank Pym Scott
Lang becomes part of the Avengers you
can see where this is going it's going
to be like the first Iron Man movie you
know whenever Nick Fury and Coulson
approached Tony Stark Avengers 3 is a
long way off
but it's likely during that movie that
Paul Rudd will be one of the second-tier
Avengers like Black Widow and Hawkeye
and Avengers
we don't know what parts of the comic
they're including in this story but if
you do want to read comics with Scott
Lang's run as ant-man start with
Avengers number one eight one he didn't
become ant-man until later Marvel
premiere number 47 but both those comics
are from 1979 so it was a long time ago
the really cool thing that Marvel does
though is discount comic books for
upcoming movies so like right now
comiXology has a discount on all Captain
America comics real quick bonus point
though for Pym particles because they're
a big part of the ant-man story during
Scott Lang's run Pym particles actually
become a pretty big thing but because
Star Wars kind of ran afoul with
midi-chlorians
I think Marvel might cites that the
issue just a little bit but a core part
of hank pimp's character is that he's
mentally unstable as a result of
exposure to Pym particles so I'm gonna
be really interested to see how Michael
Douglas portrays this on-screen you know
if they try to sidestep this really
technical thing I always kind of thought
of him as a crazier version of Tony
Stark which kind of explains how he
could be responsible for creating Ultron
but since the movies are changing all
that they might also change pimp's
personality just a little bit too but
Michael Douglas kind of is a cranky old
man so it kind of works so now it's your
turn let me know what are you looking
forward to most in ant-man and what kind
of Ultron Easter eggs do you think we're
gonna see Marvel has been really famous
for Easter eggs and post-credit scenes
remember the NYX movie after a man was
just announced as being Captain America
3 so there's at least going to be some
sort of shield presence at the end of
that movie so in related news new
Avengers 2 footage coming tonight I'll
be posting a breakdown to that later you
can click here to watch that video I'll
add the annotation as soon as I post it
and click here to learn more about
Avengers 2 thank you so much for
watching I'll see you guys tonight
high fives
you